what's up alienation I used to get sick
a lot I used to believe that if I didn't
eat the right food that would get sick
that if I didn't sleep the right number
of hours I would get sick that if
anybody around me was sick that I would
get sick and guess what happened
I got sick a lot and then in January of
this year after getting really sick I
decided I am never going to get sick
again never sick again I'm always going
to be healthy and dedicated myself to
learning from some of the Masters people
who have figured it out for themselves
on how to never get sick so that also
spawned this new series called never
sick and today we're going to learn from
wim HOF the Iceman on his techniques his
strategies his secrets to never get this
and as always guys as Lynn was talking
if he says something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below put quotes around it
so others can enjoy
[Music]
to me God is full you could say that I
think of the goal as a noble course it's
just helping me it's training me it's
bringing me back to the inner nature the
way it was mentally and this way I be
not only Angelo Nicole I love the cool
[Music]
we live in a world where there's all
kinds of false healers and take
alternative medicine programs you can
sign up for it's a rare moment in
history when someone comes along who can
perform real miracles with real evidence
to back them up wim Hof's has defied
logic time and time again and always
under scientific scrutiny
he holds the world record for being able
to be submerged in ice for almost two
hours in that his core body temperature
changing he's climbed Mount Everest and
nothing would a pair of short and ran a
marathon in the desert without drinking
any water
he's even proven in a laboratory setting
that he can withstand illnesses using
the power of his mind but he's not a
freak of nature according to whim anyone
can do what he can do they just have to
learn his method the wim HOF method
using a combination of cold immersion
breathing technique and mental focus
anyone can accomplish feats that were
previously thought to be impossible in
the hospital a harvest can evade the
solitude is good yeah an advanced
outcome Akama simple two months ago no
madam enter middle civilities Monica
Technica and relative oxidized Minutemen
renovations under hope recently I
created a method the component are
breathing mindset and cold exposure
gradual non forced cold exposure and
that's to optimize the mind-body
connection women have figured out ways
namely to breath work and to exposure to
cold to take conscious control over
aspects of its physiology that for most
people they simply can't tune into and
control
[Music]
the cold my warmth friend it brings
about a whole lot of more energy in that
room together with breathing makes you
so powerful but then you lose your wife
and a dole rumbles down for children and
with my one and there was to be with her
father she was the love of my life she
died she suicided it's a it's a black
hole within yourself it breaks your
heart and you don't know why but the
Train of a daily life it's going on and
you gotta catch up otherwise you lose it
so I had to be there for my children and
yes we created a new nest my children
made me survive in that time but nature
yields my work the cold gave me a direct
understanding of deeper breathing and
how to heal a broken heart then I went
did all kinds of remarkable challenges
apparently they found it a very
remarkable and great and particular soul
came in contact with television one
after the other they challenged me more
more more more MORE they go swim 50
meters are under the eyes go as swim
hundred meters under the earth Clarke
Mount Everest ensures that Ladakh that
the scientists became curious a what
this man is doing is not possible
physiologically
the science of what wim HOF method does
is one of the primary interests of my
lab now because it is so powerful and
it's been shown to be powerful in the
immune system we believe it will also
hold some real potential for treatment
of neurologic diseases and this
breathing technique brings you right
into the deepest part of our physiology
anybody can do so you become the
alchemist of your own chemistry the
first time I went under the earth what
is a sharp of needles I saw this as a
big huge shop diamond at 35 meters I
lost sight because the retina it froze I
couldn't see nothing I couldn't breathe
of course
and then my consciousness succumbed to a
lower consciousness to survive I do not
fear yet I fear not to live fully if I
left early I'm not into that
I'm living
it isn't all about breaking records Wims
mission is to use his body as a
laboratory to revolutionize our
understanding of physiology in 2011 he
was injected with the bacterial
endotoxin in an experiment that
challenged our understanding of the
nervous system in normal humans the
injection should cause a strong immune
response leading to fever chills and
headache but not and when it appears
that he was somehow able to suppress his
immune response by making his body
secrete adrenaline suggesting that his
method can allow us to influence our
immune system at will scientists thought
he might just be a freak of nature so to
further prove this theory they perform
the same experiment on 12 subjects women
trained in Poland and the same thing
happened normally it's very difficult to
increase your adrenaline levels by your
own will adrenaline is released by the
autonomic nervous system and autonomic
means that you cannot voluntarily
influence it so if you walk outside and
you are wrapped on the street you will
have a heart rate of 160 your blood
pressure will be sky-high within seconds
but if I ask you now to increase your
heart rate you cannot do that you cannot
voluntarily modulate that and with the
techniques of wim HOF we show that he
was able to increase his adrenaline
levels to fairly high concentrations
even higher than people that go bungee
jumping for the first time there was
something that we didn't think possible
before that right now we are right over
here 750 meters we go up to 41 degrees
is that the copper from the copper will
go to visca and it goes
oh you studied math you are go Peter and
I just don't think but hope [ __ ] your
body to be able cope the elements up
there and you will be able and without
you are going to show for yourself hey
man I can do this Wow you ever wanted a
real test of the wim HOF method this is
it
if you concentrate hard enough this snow
looks like sand in it you just feel like
you're at the beach exactly that's the
mind if your mind is on it and you're
quite capable of dealing with the
elements yeah
because it is a bit nippy really yeah
dude
there's a method to this we're doing is
breathing in more oxygen than I need and
then breathing out without fully letting
go during that five times and on the
final breath squeezing the oxygen into
your chest neck and head and that
creates either real or illusionary Heat
and then you let go that's how we get
the top of the mountain okay Mike random
pod miner crab pot emergency right
there are a few theories as to why wim
Hof's can do what you can do one is that
he has a higher level of brown adipose
tissue or Browns back in his body which
is a heat generating tissue in the body
studies have shown that people who work
outside in the cold have higher levels
of brown fat so it's possible that he's
able to manipulate the level of brown
fat in his body by exposure to cold like
we're doing right now another theory is
that he's able to secrete the hormone
noradrenaline at will through breathing
and by jumping into cold water and that
adrenaline allows us to overcome
coldness and illness another theory is
that he uses a form of meditation
similar to the Tibetan
tumor meditation which by shutting off
the activity of the mind your metabolism
gets redirected into generating heat
it's probably a combination of all those
three and some as of yet unexplained
physiological phenomena as well but when
takes a step further he says that using
his method you can go deep into the body
and actually control your own
autonomic nervous system and a music I
want to do scientific scrutiny of
research and put me to the test
and they saw amazing things but then
they said you know what eyes when you
are just one test subject and I said no
what I can do anybody can do you can
just start doing this difference and you
can modulate your adrenaline levels by
women stress hormones are able to
motivate your immune response there are
many diseases that are influenced by
origins and you can imagine that it will
be of interest if you could modulate
that they need response and suppress it
that it might be offensive to patients
with piece like that how did it feel
when you finally got recognition from
the science world that your methods work
I cried really you know what happened
your wife whom you loved so dearly keep
suicide you don't understand you just
don't understand you're half your power
animal and finally because you have been
everywhere looking for how to silence
degrees finally get scientific
recognition that's the time when you
break that's the time when you can move
you can't let go it's when you try look
at look at the glass
oh whoa Wow Wow
mother holy mama it's nicer oh it's
amazing the body human you actually for
yes to natural ability to cross the
border from pole is Patricia collection
and now we're just about in the Czech
Republic
in a short cloud our line all the way
good how you feeling I feel good once
again back home
[Music]
they ask the professors and all the
scientific world what's happening with
this guy because this is not possible
they're genetically the same imprint my
brother and they see he is not capable
of doing what he is capable of and why
because I just go deeper
it's by breeding if we just breathe more
deeply change the chemistry inside not
shallow breathing deep breathing slowly
but surely this is what you do
consciously can you do this 30 times the
chemistry in the body in the tissues is
changed and it's changing so that the
body is becoming Oxana yet alkaline and
then suddenly the brain-body connection
is possible by pressurizing by one you
begin to have that connection with the
body then you are able to connect with
it in the brain and that's what we do
right now with Stanford University to
get rid of PTSD fear trauma and
depression to learn to expand
consciousness and together with
breathing you create the right chemistry
and then the neurons they channel up and
thus your perception your consciousness
is going to be you smell more you see
their colors brighter you experience
deeper and that's the brain and then
connecting once again with all the cells
makes you a beautiful living B are you
ready we let deeply in and let them
deeply and let go once again deep in
make it circle feel lightness luminous
in the body
lightness Linda had tingling in your
fingers make it effective we have to get
rid of the co2 in the body that will
enrich the opsonization that will enrich
the o2 the oxygen within the body and we
need the oxygen in this exercise this
exercise consists of 30 breaths boolean
let go fully let go Samba some people
will do it by the mouth some people will
do it by the nose who cares just do it
co2 reduction is what we want is what we
aim for
thus OH - or oxygen will and be enriched
in all the body and we well consume that
oh - that enriched Oh - the oxygen by
doing push-ups without breathing she
will show that she is able she told me
she could do like 10 push-ups let us see
how many pushups she is going to do
without breathing we'll see okay five
more
she is focused as you can see and that's
what we need to release the right
hormones which make you stronger
dopamine serotonin adrenaline and it's
all concentrated by the mind you can
control this hormone and there she goes
okay without breathing 20 Wow look at
her 22 as the exercise with the shower
the shower exercise to train the
cardiovascular system we get the muscles
everywhere in the system I'm one hundred
thousand two kilometers so we are going
to trigger it Wow our by not joking when
you go into a culture in the beginning
of course of the course you go from the
heat to the cold your body learns to
adapt I mean that veins live into them
and they are triggered the muscles work
and in a couple of days it's bearable
you can do because the condition
elevates right now I'm going to go into
this culture what should you do at
mental focus I'm gonna do this whole
heartedly I'm not that there and there
with my mind's and right over here okay
that's number one and the second is
the breath the breath is inside as you
know and it can control and you have
learned to use this manipulate
dramatically the poorest of the breath
within and it triggers the nervous
system and the cardiovascular so if you
control by referring to your breath
study you'll control
he is a trained person of course my
cardiovascular system works almost
directly on it so it closes up down here
around the liver the lungs the heart and
that adds you know the brain there's a
full temperature needs to be the same
always so close it and that's what I did
my mind just before just when I talk to
you right now and you can learn this too
actually it's to elevate your power
which you got already over there in time
and for the rest of a nice shower if you
feel like then that means it's not
closing right that's why you are joking
so learn to have the right
cardiovascular system by following the
steps up first off thanks for a little
bit folder up and bringing it to really
cold and then directly like this
directly into the call and have a great
challenge because your cardiovascular
system is great
why I teach this method to show that
with a simple method out of nature we
are able to tackle the greatest problems
which is depression fear anxiety and
pain people with chronic pain that's all
unnecessary suffering going on and all
this industry's keeping on and say yeah
that's normal and I think that's thick
as it turns out that non ingestible
approaches such as breath work or cold
exposure can approach some of the
potency that medications can provide or
have failed to provide then it's quite
possible that one can heal from the
inside that's what we found to prove to
tap into our body and mind and abling us
to become happy strong healthy
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video are you
inspired fired if you take something
from it you're going to learn more about
it are you going to try this breathing
and cold exposure strategy I've been
testing it myself so far getting some
early results but I'm excited to
continue the test are you guys going to
try it I love to know your thoughts on
this video as well as the series you
want to continue this series and profile
other people and their thoughts on never
getting sick again
leave it in the comments below I'm super
curious to find out and I'm going to
join in the discussion finally want to
give a quick chatter - Victor Lim Victor
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book your one word I really really
really really appreciate your support
and I hope you enjoyed so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever we're one where it is much
love please